c'est l'un des grands événements
cinématographiques de la rentrée la
sortie mercredi du film le colonel
chabert première réalisation d'yves
angelo le talentueux chef opérateur de
nocturne indien un coeur en hiver ou
encore tous les matins du monde
librement adapté du roman de balzac le
colonel chabert et l'histoire de la
résurrection gênante d'un mort d'un
glorieux soldats de l'anp pire que l'on
a cru tué lors de la bataille d'eylau et
qui va lutter farouchement pour
retrouver son nom et parle à son honneur
le colonel chabert est interprété par
gérard depardieu qui a rencontré nicolas
cornu l'endroit jaber
colonel commandé un régiment de
cavalerie à lots où je suis mort le 8
février 1807 gérard depardieu et
chabbert homme foudroyé pathétique mais
jamais pitoyable c'est quelqu'un qui
essaye de se faire accepter
c'est quelqu'un qu'on refuse
c'est quelqu'un qui a été tuée qui n'est
pas mort
s'aperçoit qu'on ne veut pas de
réintégrer parce qu'il ya trop
d'intérêts en jeu alors là ça devient un
conflit magnifique à jouer c'est
difficile à vivre
j'ai certainement difficile à vivre une
perte d'identité la mémoire c'est comme
ça en tout cas la mienne
tout est éteint
sauf
top des endroits
qui brillent comme des brasiers
aussi deux états
c'est en mettant un ferme et tenter
toujours la vie d'une carte au tribunal
les personnages de balzac son double
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu il ya le bien
et le mal il ya le noir et le blanc il
ya il ya cette force quand tous les
personnages balzac du plus minables au
plus élégant charenton soient tués vous
seriez prix et guillotine ni comme un
misérable je vais reprendre la plaque de
ma légion d'honneur
elle a confié un graveur il est bien
inscrire votre nom et renoncer à trouver
cette femme que vous seriez capable de
manquer ce qui serait une faute
impardonnable affaires judiciaires fable
ou réalité balzac gorée d'aimer cette
rencontre chabert depardieu deux
personnages hors du commun
grandiose